good morning believe nation if you or
friend of yours are having a hard time
deciding between whether you should go
out and do the smart thing the safe
thing and get a job or launch your own
business I'm going to share with you a
clip from Jim Carrey that I hope will
help you
you can spend your whole life imagining
ghosts worrying about the pathway to the
future but all there will ever be is
what's happening here in the decisions
we make in this moment which are based
in either love or fear so many of us
choose our path out of fear disguised as
practicality what we really want seems
impossibly out of reach and ridiculous
to expect so we never dare to ask the
universe for it I'm saying I'm the proof
that you can ask the universe for it and
if it doesn't happen for you right away
it's only because the universe is so
busy fulfilling my order
my father could have been a great
comedian but he didn't believe that that
was possible for him and so he made a
conservative choice instead he got a
safe job as an accountant and when I was
12 years old he was let go from that
safe job and our family had to do
whatever we could to survive I learned
many great lessons from my father not
the least of which was that you can fail
at what you don't want so you might as
well take a chance on doing what you
love so my quick take on this is a lot
of people will tell you to do the smart
thing the safe thing go get a job look
for a big company and in my view there's
nothing riskier than putting your life
into somebody else's hands that's
especially the case when you don't
absolutely love what you do you see the
people who rise to the top and any
industry you look at the top people in
any industry they love what they do
their passion about it there's no way
you can get to the top of your industry
if you don't love it because you're not
gonna put in the hours the energy the
effort the creativity you're not gonna
be dreaming about it you're not gonna be
talking to your family about it there's
no way you're gonna get to the top
because you don't love it enough so if
you have this secret idea that you
really want to be an entrepreneur and
you're forced to then go get a job
because that's what society says is the
safe thing to do that's actually the
riskiest thing to do because you're
handing your life over to somebody else
and you're doing something that you're
not absolutely passionate about so
although it's scary although you're
venturing into the unknown although you
may be doing something that your family
and friends don't agree with you have to
follow your heart with all big decisions
and if that company something you want
to do you have to go and do it thank you
guys so much for watching my question of
the day for you is I'd love to know
somebody in your life whether it's
yourself or a family member or a friend
who was like Jim Carrey's dad who did
the smart thing the safe thing and it
ended up falling apart on them I'd love
to hear those stories if you want to
leave it in the comments below because I
think it can help inspire a lot of
people to want
that step so if you have that story
please share it in the comments below
and of course if you like this video and
you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter have a fantastic day I hope
I'll see you again tomorrow morning at 7
a.m. to help kick start your day with
another inspirational video believe